this is one of those films that's had a  few release dates  and something always seems to come up  have you guys actually tried picking up  the phone  and calling people and said look there's  this thing called disney plus  they have hulu do we want to say effort  and just  put it out yeah  they may have had the idea yeah  we're in the same boat as most movies  you know you sign contracts that sort of  guarantee a theatrical release so it  needs to  open to ever go digital in the first  place but uh we just too  would like people to see it in the  theater but uh it needs to obviously be  at the right time when it's safe to go  back  have any of you called anyone and said  hey you know there's this thing called  disney plus  i speak regularly to the guys at disney  and  i'm i'm told that this is the plan is to  go theatrical  so we're i'm happy with that wait no no  totally i'm just messing with you guys